yeah alright ladies and gentlemens the
psoriasis kid and bad tummy
here we are right you alright you'd be a
little better today yeah I started a
meal plan only one cup of coffee put a
little baking soda in my coffee nice
nice bubbles out the acidic level sure
sure I know that no I look like I look
like a red pineapple it doesn't here's
the thing worse
this is spreading it's just getting on
my forearms that's the thing is you not
do anything to fix it no I'm not I'm
trying to no I changed my diet radically
it's gonna take some time now well what
I like to do is I like to get a flare-up
and then I like to eat drink a shitload
of wine and eat a whole bunch of bread
and that's good for me the good stuff is
all that [ __ ] apparently I don't know
who says that house it's it when you
look at consensus but you know the bla
[ __ ] annoying thing about our health
care is like you know doctors it's not
an exact science and doctors are like
hmm I don't know I said the doctor I
went to on Sunday I go you know you guys
don't really know a lot about nutrition
I mean he goes we sure don't I don't
know anything about the successful tea
now it's not what they do
I was like you see a specialist well
when I went to that doc didn't you say
about my stomach date I mean you tell
them the Simpson Ashley stomach you tell
their symptoms like yeah and I would
just cut out on the coffee will
prescribe these pills like no [ __ ] I
guess just give me the pills this is
what this is what happened that's what
doctors say I talked to one of the big
internists cuz he saw my buddy who died
of pancreatic cancer so I talked to him
about that and I talked about you know
honestly we don't really know a lot of
times it's probably like a like the
bacteria in your stomach gets thrown out
of whack and then it just causes pain or
problems those general doctors god damn
yeah I really have to see a specialist
we're gonna try to drug you it you're
gonna drug here they're gonna cut you
it's not nothing against them and
sometimes they save your life sometimes
I make you better for sure I'm not I'm
not so anti drug guy actually help hi
great they help now if you take him for
a long long time about being trouble but
there's a reason antibiotics are
important oh [ __ ] yes
hell yes I'm never that guy like all
they're just they're just pushing the
syphilis don't do end about it tell me
how it works on your jack
yeah okay relax Eddie bro now it helps
the antibiotics save lives yes they say
and and they keep you from getting your
arm cut off because it becomes gangrene
etc etc painkillers are different can be
a different piece but again if you're
having major surgery
oh oh oh you think they're pushing the
agenda go that painkillers when you get
no sir excuse me sir I smoke your weed
let me know how that fixes you know
double for yeah I had my nose and my
septum was torn in half and pushed
backwards I had my septum fixed and that
was so painful when they hadn't unpack
your nose it's the worst and then I had
a double hernia double hernia where they
cut into your body that's a good time
actually I'm sorry they didn't cut it
they scoped it and it still was insanely
painful and I got i whoa i can't do and
a woman goes this big Jamaican nurse she
said you feel uncomfortable I got Nam
all right I was in so much pain she goes
now you feel uncomfortable they hit me
with a little uh little a little
morphine or whatever it was we you don't
become addicted no you don't but goddamn
patient through that pain can be
debilitating certain pain you're you're
not some people are in pain all the time
like their spinal cord they'd like their
there the nerve roots and their lower
I'd rather have pain like you like off
pain in my neck or whatever my back
where at elbows I'm gonna have that than
be sick though at least a pain I can
address it you take some sort of messing
that will actually kind of help a little
bit when you're sick there's not a whole
light unit you minimize it when you have
the flu and you realize how weak how
like when you have the flu and you're
getting up and throwing up you realize
how vulnerable you are oh my god I mean
you can say any amount of money to get
rid of it
oh you're just like oh I believe in God
I hey God sorry about all these ads
please please make me better please make
me better my buddy my buddy who doesn't
take care of himself eats like four men
drinks smokes we don't know he got yeah
he got sick it was in the hospital and
he was like he'd looked at doctor he
goes doc get me out of here the doctor
goes well I will but you could do me a
favor shed and he goes you could
practice some self-restraint for
something
for God's sake yes it's amazing what the
body can put up with oh you know finally
that show that I watch I haven't been
watching lately but my 600 pound live
news people over 600 pounds we have to
get on some sort of diet lose weight and
then he'll perform the surgery it's
always in Houston it's the top guest
ologist guest front ro yeah it's the top
one so it's always him with these golden
earphones but finally a guy died
finally I always was wondering finally a
gentleman died you mean on the show no
they couldn't hear because D died it
died because it's literally the
operation no because they're literally
like men this is life and ever have to
lose 200 pounds by you know in 60 days
80 degree you're gonna die are you gonna
die and he's like you have to stick this
so they'll try and stick to it and the
check in like you've gained 13 pounds
he's like and then the fat guys always
like I don't know why I'm sinking the
diet and the doctors literally like he's
bit dealt with everyone's [ __ ] it's like
that's not true that that you don't gain
30 pounds think this diet what are you
doing and then finds like I was starving
at night I'll have like you know four
pizzas he's like alright well that's not
sticking the diets messing so this guy
was doing that and then you know he died
my friend my friends don't live bad days
my friends doctor stopped working with
him cuz I can't work like this
I'm done this guy does the same thing
yeah yeah oh you know I just can't work
with you anymore
yeah you're you're literally gonna die
like I can't I'm trying to help you up
done Frank I can't help you anymore
it's frustrating man that's got it
that's in it that's alright now you're
doing with a whole psychological
emotional thing it's like you know this
guy yeah skinny at the bottom of the
poor guy see I just saw the headline
that he died let's see new jersey
resident who weighed eight hundred eight
hundred and forty-two pounds was
featured on Wednesday night's episode
where viewers learned he suffered a
heart attack during the filming of the
show
get on gone weight loss surgeons placed
on strict that before he died suddenly
of a heart attack
hands learned it was just like two Z's
Wow keeps going down man that sucks I
mean but 845 pounds it's like yeah
you're it's a form of
suicide right I mean you know I mean
it's a form of kind of and then they
want to get better but this just it's
almost too late to you know it's it's
such a bummer how big was his wife or
his fiancee not skinny chin thank you
thank you for asking how this give me
hot skin the usually usually if he's if
she's getting him for pizzas the night
she's eating - I know this is a really
weird thing to say and I and I admire it
cuz I wish I could just kind of do that
I'd had an image when you said that of
me being between them and being all like
like I like a threesome no just like who
wants to get between these guys who it's
all soft it's not soft and a lot of have
barnacles I don't know if you ever seen
that they have barnacles hanging off
their legs Brian yeah and school I think
you have problems they've sores yeah and
some of their feet literally look like
elephant's feet like it turned yeah
being a green and there's like there's
like the sertao shoes on and the
circulations bad it's just like hanging
off well they must be so diabetic right
that's at least diabetic yeah that's
like that's like child's play
yeah that's why that's like ha ha ha
that sucks but uh - or 842 pounds yeah
that's a I don't have seen the scales
they get on now it literally looks like
when you go to UPS the way your packages
they like they're it's a size that couch
they get on I think damn it's so
interesting I don't know some of it some
of them do it and that the other bummer
is they can't leave their beds and when
they have kids and stuff it's a bummer
and the kids end up taking care of them
it's you remember what super summer
we're eating What's Eating Gilbert Grape
right
I don't oh I've seen it Oh baby yes dude
and the woman see if she's still alive
Fenton that the woman who plays a very
heavy woman in that is it's incredible
that's a hell of a movie yeah I want a
bunch of wards just literally cap Rios
MA and his mom is no peace woman yeah
and I won't give it away might be tough
in the end they can't get her get its
1993 can spoiler at that price they
can't get her out of the house Darlene
Cates has to be very might be does she
die uh yeah and then they you know burn
the house down
you know some of these people Jesus
Christ you know some of these people on
my sticks are found life that so it
the ambulance has to come and a lot of
times they cut out the doorway to get
him out it takes several men in English
Eating Gilbert Grape they she dies
upstairs and they can't get her down and
decide to burn the house down
no better yeah she died last year she
died last year I was crazy what Brendan
I don't know we all were you're uh I'll
take a heart attack for 3,000 Alex yeah
she was older I think um in her sleep
that's the age of 69 it's a good run
that's a good run 69 good for her though
yeah hold on she was on uh Oh No good
actress man she was really good in that
movie I mean she didn't do much other
than that god bless her
yeah that's tough go yeah man I don't
know it's like some people are just born
with this weird affliction gambling you
it said they did extremes like the did
to extreme left under but you they show
their family their families all big like
there's one family there's a Shawn I
think it's TLC one of those channels
where all the family members are all
over three four hundred pounds there's
like eight of them was just a family and
that what that's what I'm seeing is like
so if so if your parents were a beast
you have something like 300 percent more
likely chance to be a beast as well like
a lot of its genetic the way you eat and
then for some of it like land you guys
Mike what the [ __ ] man but you know I
balls deep in team Teen Mom D mom and
there's a I forget her name on there
Kaitlyn but she she's a bigger girl and
she had miscarriage
it's called Teen Mom right so she had a
miscarriage on there and then through
all her problems of you know her way
she's on the public I strike him in
suicide and she had to check in to get
help
yeah but they then they the what the
therapist does it's brilliant even think
about this so they're shown it obvious I
should notice there's a grown man in
America when you go to the therapy a lot
of times they bring the family can you
have the therapy with the family and
find out that all her a lot of her
problems stem from her family her mom is
a drug addict her dad was missing her
dad did this or you know her mom did
this and adds up all this stuff and the
therapist goes through all that it's an
emotional thing but you also have to
have extremes like um
evolutionary biologist genetics
always talk about this I've heard them
discuss this stuff where like you you to
have a normal like most of us are normal
right like we're pretty normal in terms
of you know we're not extreme right so
we discern them out yeah well you
sometimes you have dark thoughts and
eyes you have light thoughts whatever we
printable you're pretty level and when
you're an actor like your acting teacher
will always say stuff like do you have
everything in you you know you have a
serial killer and you you have a saint
in you you just have to know where to
find it in your in cities right but in
order for that to be the case you have
to have aberrations on either side so
you have to have demonic males you have
to have team you know that for an
example is in yeah well no no because I
guess when it comes to certain genetic
factors you're gonna have people that
are super skinny and super fat so you
can have the middle ground yeah and
that's how genetics works and it plays
out you know apparently in even behavior
mental behaviors you have to have like
true predator as we associate as over
here yes Razi's and then over there you
have this super kind it's like it's just
the way it is and you will probably
couldn't have the balance without those
two extreme that's why when people refer
does the one-percenters in they referred
to in sports and I've seen motorcycle
gangs as well but yeah the
one-percenters you need a one percenters
in every hundred percent man serial
killers they're on bridge yes and yes
mentally ill one person and actors one
percent of comics one check this out and
and one of the files one when they were
looking at Ted Kaczynski who was John
Gotti's number one trigger man he was
hit because the tech in this key sorry
you know bomber was the Bob Mayo Richard
his name is Richard or something uh find
out what the Gottis the Gambino family's
number one hit man was he was called the
Iceman the bull remember the Iceman
Sammy the bull say I'm an abused the
snitch but the Iceman had a so the
Iceman would tie people up have let rats
eat him call casa [ __ ] he killed you
really smart first West step as a woman
and spin dragged and spilled a drink of
cyanide on a guy guy died got in his
clothes he was a master and he was six
foot four three hundred and five pounds
and not not that fat um Charles no no no
it no his
was stabilized the Iceman Iceman yeah
Iceman and they did a whole thing on him
anyway they did a profile on him right
and they had this famous psychiatrist do
a profile on the guy right and what they
found was they were like Richard who's
the cool in Schuylkill Lenski you got to
hear him interviewed it's chilling
it's [ __ ] there's a YouTube video you
know I might hear this so [ __ ] and he
wanted to see how then he wanted to see
how its crossbow worked and so he asked
a guy for directions the guy came to his
to the car window and he shot him
through the head with it
and he goes how that works and he goes
but you didn't know you didn't know the
man didn't know the man he goes see he
just killed him like that now didn't
know him yet and he got this [ __ ] beaten
out of him by Stu had two daughters
loved his daughters loved his kids good
father decided to talk to me oh it looks
like well basically I think I tried it I
decided to talk to you was would be so I
could find out more about myself since I
don't know the answers and you are a
person who is highly qualified
interesting
oof I can live with that
get here's a sinister smile that oh yeah
dude he was so cool happens I might have
a question for you see you can see is
insecure he's never had to be talked
this way mr. crudd no he's just he's
embarrassed cuz he can't think of
something
he doesn't wanna look dumb we discover
you think what a baller about me
who doesn't think good better and
different that's the best you come up
with some of each he can only relate to
himself yeah you bet the issues about
your behavior and there are two types of
personality features then you have a
great deal of the first sometimes called
antisocial personality disorder what it
refers to behaviorally is someone who
does not have a conscience does not have
remorse does not feel a sense of guilt
about most of the bad things they do
that because impulsive and violent the
typical things we see before age 15 and
people who earn that label are cruelty
toward animals cruelty toward people and
an awfully interesting part of that what
would be able to play Houston okay if
all this stuff so I'll give you a couple
things he did so so here's here's here's
what the psychiatrist said first you
have antisocial behavior okay which
means you don't have a conscience you
don't have her Morrison stuff are you
listening and then second he said I said
a lot of that the thing is that you you
that's okay to have because some people
who have that he said also get that
coupled with the fact that you're a
risk-taker you don't get nervous at all
he said he doesn't get nervous so race
car drivers elite commandos they tend to
not get as nervous as people so his
heart rate doesn't raise so there are
two things he's got going for him one is
that and he said the second I've said if
you hadn't had a father will beat the
[ __ ] out of you you might have been like
a racecar driver a stuntman
somebody took great risks either
our fighter all that but because you
were damaged and so destroyed he was
beaten his father beat the [ __ ] out he
and his brother his brothers in jail for
murder and and when he was in jail with
his brother they never said anything to
each other why because his brother was
in jail for multiple murders he's in
jail from ultimate boat doing life
sentences and he said he walked by his
brother once as brothers today what
somebody goes hey what's up that's it
and they they came under the same father
who used to beat the [ __ ] out of them
for no reason all the time so his father
destroyed them so so whatever happened
in their personality was destroyed a
long time ago who knows what the head
trauma and if there's a lot of people
who get beat bother his father was
apparently absolutely said satanic I
mean he was awful he was called - how
many people are this many so he so he
was driving one time and when he was a
hit man and these four dudes in a van
cut him off and then they started
[ __ ] with him they were like they
were toughs you know local top snare
like you [ __ ] [ __ ] and all that
stuff so guess what he did he pulled
over and then they pulled over and the
problem was they got out to fight the
whole know he shot all four of course he
shot all four of them they were just
lying about like cordwood it was like
they see him though exactly
well they didn't know they didn't know
they were dealing with with John Gotti's
number one hit man a giant man who
didn't give a [ __ ] about what's it say
what says death wait did he die chitin
he died yeah yeah of what a bad heart
for not being able to kiss part was made
of he died at 70 his heart was made
information and blood vessels and he had
a he had a he had a Hornet our head he
had a tar Hornet heart con man right so
dark [ __ ] this guy he said you know guy
what John Gotti's uh nephew them and
they Fido no really bringing that up
Gotti yo my man he said that this guy
this other guy he was in about side of
bar on this guy was a loudmouth he's
being a dick and then and kind of being
a bullying stuff so so he goes he waited
to the guy was outside and he he he took
a belt wrapped it around a guy's throat
and then turned his back and kind of
pulled the guy over his back and just
just killed him that way and then just
went in the bar and had a drink and
nobody knew what the [ __ ] happened like
guys just dead outside
yeah look at that John got his nephew
you know a grandson grandson yeah he's a
fighter
I think he's doing pretty well too I
thought it was mine you think he's doing
well John there's a john frusciante
walters playing John Gotti in the new
really yeah biopic that'll be
interesting John Gotti was a character
that dude used to that [ __ ] guy used
to bet he was such a compulsive Cage
wanna know so he was such a competitive
gambler he would do [ __ ] like um they'd
make to cockroaches and he would put
crazy money on which cockroach exhaust
and so when they were they were they had
his wiretap you know I tapped him do you
ever hear how they tapped this [ __ ]
guy they got into the ravenite social
club which was right on Mulberry Street
I used to I used to eat in a place
called Cafe Sorrento right in here it
might be still there the ravenite social
club right a cop a woman got in she was
attractive very attractive standard she
got in there she let the dude he used to
run the ravenite Club he'd clean up
afterwards and you do that apparently
and it's pretty pretty stingy she let
that guy bang her and she placed that
[ __ ] bug under the table whatever it
takes whatever it takes brother
god bless her god bless her and that's
how they were able to that was one of
the ways they were able to get like some
serious [ __ ] she got in there she and
that guy they found that that guy had
[ __ ] up but they'd never killed him
they were like it's just the way it is
you know what [ __ ] up she they were
good good on then Wow
yeah good on them um it's pretty wild
the John Gotti died too in prison right
he wasn't in Colorado got throat cancer
and [ __ ] that's right yeah he was
desperate to get out of jail all those
guys are they say El Chapo they're
complaining how they're not treating him
very nice he's going crazy in solitary
confine her I thought well oh yeah we
got mad yeah he didn't live it though he
never did he was he was a tough guy he
was I wonder why like especially
Americans I guess the world but they're
obsessed with like you look at all the
well the bad people the shows like
narcos and El Chapo
and Scarface and Goodfellas and
everything got the Godfather Sopranos
like were obsessed with these horrible
people yeah I guess all people wearing
El Chapo's shirts at Disneyland like
morons any idea what he represents if
any idea how many people he killed kids
women yeah that's going on or how many
kid is a reason why go to Supermax and
he has her wearing these [ __ ] t-shirt
you see that man's a hero
they're both Mexican descent you have
any idea what he represents right that's
like me my feeling were in a Jeffrey
Dahmer stir there's no difference and
he's killed Wayne Italian Italian
Americans always had that sort of like
tenuous relationship with you know most
times are conservative and very
obviously law-abiding but as an Italian
myself you know that you'd go to runts
you go to like delis and it'd be like a
poster of like The Godfather and stuff
and you know it's like it highlights
there yeah romantic right were there
they're outlaws but also but also with
like the talent mafia they didn't kill
civilians really they killed their own
there was a code that was with the
cartels and really just the cartels now
in Mexico they go after you're fit
they're the ones who changed the game
gone after your family that's nice to
carry us took over yeah but like the
Mafia the Italian mafia was always very
disciplined Family Values like you never
went after the family ever never and I
was that was always so important but you
know then again was Jewish mafia
switched the game because the the their
family whose success in mafia their
their their kids and their stuff they
didn't go oh you're in get in the Mafia
no you're going to call it crack will
pay for it correct you're gonna get out
of it they got into legitimate business
yes the Italians would hide their money
in a mattress that the Jews would they
be like listen let me gotta get the [ __ ]
out this is we kids are all gonna be
doctors and lawyers [ __ ] this business
and by the way we're also going to
invest our money into real estate and
get into legitimate business because at
the end of the day if you take on the
government you're gonna be [ __ ] but
also if you're if you're a crime boss
has that you've seen every movie scene
every story it's never ever worked out
for any none ever with you
head of a cartel yeah gang whatever it
is it's never been like look at that
like there's not even exception like
look at Geoffrey now he's on this show
now he's killed a man living life in
Florida now that's taking that to go
it's a lot of like criminals are drawn
to it that they're born criminals in a
way like it's it didn't do anything else
yeah there's like the excitement live
live die young and leave a good-looking
corpse II liked it it's also the same as
like athletes to you you have this short
window make all this money it's like
dude you know when this is over I'll
cease completely different I'm just
drawn around but it's what's completely
over you know it's not gonna be the same
then they try to put them in regular
civilian life behind a five they don't
fit in it's really these guys yes and
with soldiers some soldiers are addicted
to warfare in the adrenaline and they're
a team that they have a mission and then
they get done and you put them in the
back inside and like this is this socks
man where's my bros where's the team
Vaughn oh they said when he got arrested
they got yeah he's witness protection
and that thing that they had
investigator goes yeah that's fine he'll
be back he's gonna [ __ ] up because
there's no other way of course he I
think he got caught for it running a
huge ecstasy ring it's like yeah he also
killed 19 people but it's also like yeah
of course they're gonna [ __ ] up because
a they they have their master's degree
in criminology they know exactly what
they're doing and I will know dude just
be cool go work at Red Robin Red Robin
hold on you realize in a day I made more
money than this [ __ ] place makes in a
year you want me to just succumb to this
that's the problem yeah you know [ __ ]
around it's a really interesting it's a
really interesting profile so I just did
a podcast on mixed mental arts with Gary
Nez nur Mesmer he wrote stalling for
time
he was the chief FBI hostage negotiator
for
Waco Texas who didn't go whoa whoa and
he when he got there when he [ __ ] got
there that's a [ __ ] up situation
oh well for ATF guys have been killed
and 17 wounded the but also the you know
I watched that that has a whole
documentary that they did
on that the way our our police and the
task board went about it was [ __ ] up
yeah it was so [ __ ] he came having
kids oh and there's a shooting through
the windows and stuff yes kids are
getting hit it's like who are you
shooting me it was very bad and he came
in in that situation where there were
there were huge emotions on both sides
and he had to kind of figure out a way
to talk and mean wise he's trying to
talk to the Branch Davidians they're
playing music they're doing all kinds of
like really loud they're doing all kinds
of stuff because the tactical team
wanted blood they were pissed because
they'd lost a lot of their own and also
jostle was on them though if you watch
that a lot of that's on this yes yes
well that's what he said is he was
talking about how he's really
interesting he goes there you know the
good cop bad cop stuff he goes doesn't
work you shouldn't have that he said
there's good cop/good cop be good cop
you can get so much more and what he
talked about was this he was talking to
us and I was like [ __ ] I was listening
to him and I said what do you do if
there's a situation where somebody is
not going back to jail but they're gonna
kill themselves you know they're either
gonna shoot themselves out or kill
themselves or go out on the horse and he
goes um and he was like he said well
here's the thing here's what you have
going for you they haven't done it yet
so you still have room to negotiate and
the first thing everybody he said
everybody when they talked them out the
first thing he said what got you out he
said well I don't know what remember
what you said but it was how you said it
and he said and and so the first thing
he does he goes like this he goes um I
understand you're really upset and you
know we're out here really worried about
you can you tell me what's going on and
he first thing you do is it does no
matter who they were validates he
validates their feelings yeah and and he
says you know this is this you've got
yourself in a pickle here that's got to
be you know um tell me what what you're
and they always say something like
here's the bingo moment when when he
gets them to explain what's going on
they dad nobody's heard their side of
the story finally they go like this I
don't know what to do and that's when he
was like well well I could help you well
I think you know he'll anchor you to
you'll say like this he goes you know
I'm getting from what you're saying I'm
starting to get what you're saying that
you don't want to kill him
but this you're not really interested in
a thing it's not your thing you want to
get this done and the guy goes I would
shoot people and he goes you know but I
remember what you said before this and I
understand your emotions are running
high but but and I really value what you
said because you said you don't want to
kill anybody and you're not and that's
not the goal here but what are you also
thinking I'm gonna kill myself as well
what do you plan on on accomplishing
like what do you think it's gonna compos
and what he'll do is he'll get like this
one guy was gonna kill himself didn't
want to talk wasn't talking to the cops
so what then so so you guys alright he
has a dog in the backyard he's old and
he's lonely
so you goes they blast out he goes we're
gonna we're gonna come in the backyard
we don't any trouble but we're gonna
coming backyard and make sure your dog
is fed and watered because you know your
dog looks like he's hungry
it looks like he's very agitated we're
gonna take the dog and put him in a safe
place don't you take picks up the phone
don't you touch my dog now he's got the
dog now he good realizes that the guy
wants talking to ghosts do you think
your dog will be really sad if you kill
yourself and now he's in because I [ __ ]
yeah
and so the lady wait he was I [ __ ]
talk and he goes you could use this with
terrorists you could've used this with
everything and the way he was talking I
was like and you could use it Mahalo tix
cuz he's in the business of what
persuasion persuasion communicate we
always forget that you want to persuade
you want to be heard yeah they want to
be heard no one ever see Muhammad Ali
talked to guy off from committing
suicide you're seeing that bring up
Muhammad Ali suicide yeah some eat he
was in some neighbor I think might be
New York I might be wrong on this but
even solvent guy was about to jump me
goes up then he was hey man what's going
on and just talk to the dude so check
this out check this out III remember
that actually check this out he
basically that there were these the huge
demonstrations like all these people in
a Puerto Rican airfield and they were
not gonna leave and there were bombs
there and they were can leave and the
FBI had all they had this all their
tactical squads and they were gonna
Surprise them at five different teams
they were to come in and surprise him
and they're gonna get him and put attack
him and hold him down and get him out of
there right
they had trucks and everything and he
goes like this and hostage negotiator
nothing goes well um
can we talk to them first do you think
and they go that because anything we
could talk to him so they put on that
they put on a khaki pants and a polo
shirt and walked out and they went like
this they go hey can you tell us who's
nobody's in charge William but is there
anybody using yeah well I'm the one that
he goes because hey listen um we're were
they worried about your safety though
because the problem was is that we have
unexploded ordinances there so if
there's any way we get you guys to move
um come off here maybe we could talk
about it somewhere else but we're really
concerned for your safety and every one
of them was like oh yes okay and they
all just got in their cars and left it's
funny or in the Killian remember the
Achille Lauro where the Palestinian
terrorists basically got a hold of a
cruise ship four of them a cruise ship
and threw the guy klinghoffer in a
wheelchair off off he was a Jew a Jew
and he was he was basically yelling at
them and they took him and threw him in
the ocean he done the Italian police
yeah the Italian police caught him
these are Palestinian they were under
Abu Nidal that they hardened terrorists
the Italian police puts them through
there basically we're basically like
torturing I'm doing all kinds of [ __ ]
couldn't get [ __ ] out of him couldn't
get [ __ ] I guess what guess what these
guys did two negotiators one guy who
spoke fluent Arabic they kid they sit
him down these are hard guys first thing
they did is what he goes gotta tell you
man I am so it's amazing how above just
the four of you the four of you were
able to contain over an entire crew [ __ ]
how the hell did you do that and this
carving what's the [ __ ] been there
flatter him I mean yeah flattery power
later confession in fashion it's it's
really fascinating it is it was a really
wild podcast his book is called um his
book is [ __ ] really good called
stalling for time did you see one more
one more story because you'll like this
Prison Prison Break prison prison riot
right prison riot they got a hostage
they not letting him go I think it was a
card so they stopped giving him food so
they're [ __ ] like we're not doing
anything so guess what they did they
they had the guard set just outside
their name they were hungry waited for
the winds to shift start a cooking bacon
and hamburgers on the old grill yeah
there's hot dogs starving trucks thank
you
they're like listen like this noise [ __ ]
we give up we lose well you don't but to
bring this down you know where the
comedy stores that other than that
coming store Comedy Works in Denver
you know that building mmm the building
over on Larimer my brother and cop in
them we're at lunch and some dude just
jumped off the top the video day they
sent me up videos ho ho no well people
just like get down the guys out there
and the he's like on the ledge like get
down everyone's like what's he doing up
then everyone's out with their cell
phones and then it doesn't look that
high but just when you belly-flop on the
Limerick Street the road it kind of
[ __ ] you up yeah it's just like a
normal day and then he just gee dude ah
yeah tough day in Denver a tough day in
Denver and a that's a rough that's how
there was the negotiator there well I
told you when I was where I was down
nothing 110 what's the road that goes to
like the highway where there's bridges
over it when you put you pass by like
Lockheed you pass by Tesla I don't know
what no you know I'm talking about it's
like I know exactly want to go to we do
that's Imperial highway Imperial Highway
I'm down Imperial Highway and we're and
I've told this story before but some
dudes gonna commit soon as I jump off
the bridge it's not that high you'd
really have to just nosedive into the
ground yeah that's not a very high brush
not at all he was gonna jump off there
but they stopped traffic and I was like
in the front so he could see it and then
a good negotiator there and I mean we're
there for 3-4 hours and I was just
filming it like come on man let's do
this and beam it like make a decision
yeah the old lady behind me gets out
she's eight he goes just [ __ ] do it
already and the people like do something
he was ambitious yeah man I don't want
to be late how selfish are you how I
gotta get home for dinner Boston I was
almost I almost missed my gig because a
guy was on on the on top of the thing
and then is when I finally got by he was
still up there and they started getting
traffic around but the guy was talking
to him and he was a homeless guy just
holding on to the it was so sad those
negotiators it's fascinating they're
they're fascinating and they're so good
and this guy the way he would talk like
it was so funny because you he's just
kind of an older guy and he just
soothing and it would explain things
he'd like you know and and I can
understand that you're you're really
upset here but we're really worried
about you as well
yeah something and you're like dude I
wanted yeah I want to live with you said
huh
could make me conference that was
conferences but I'll take those pancakes
by the Topsy combo oh those guys are
fascinating because they and he said oh
oh he said that there was this this area
this police department that had major
their SWAT team is always working always
working because their citizenry was
having there were a lot of violence it's
probably like a bad area so I mean they
were in get shootout some people all
this kind of stuff SWAT team squad team
SWAT team so finally the the FBI they
had the afraid come in and they trained
their police force in negotiating
tactics like they taught them some of
these things right the SWAT team armed
confrontations went down 75 percent in
one year Jesus 75 percent because when
you teach people how to talk to other
people does anyone ever get away with
those negotiations rather like I want a
helicopter 17 bars of gold Sandow he
broke he said our word he goes like this
he goes he goes he goes there's no
escape
it's never gonna never get you never get
but sometimes what they do is this so
he'll get on and get out alive yeah but
he'll get on the phone they'll go like
this this is what a lot of hostage the
people in hostage I know what you're
trying to do man I know you're trying to
do don't pull your your psychology on me
bro
yeah and he goes I'm definitely not
doing that and you know what you're
you're just trying to earn my trust and
he goes I am trying to earn your trust
that is exactly what I'm trying to do
well yeah but I've you know yes but but
what do you what do you hope to
accomplish because you know there's no
escape here right if they if you think
about it's like okay you can commit
suicide well what what what's your
agenda here let's say you do that yeah
or let's just let's say you walk out
here's your options yeah I'm trying to
do your song said he said rule is when
when and we're all like this he said
when when your your emotions are high
your rationality is low yeah and that's
how that's with everything I asked him
if it works in his marriage he's been
married 43 years he goes nope my wife is
like you're trying to pull that [ __ ]
don't it doesn't work for sure am I
right Muhammad Ali save that dude yeah
yeah I mean that's what it says here but
then there are people that think it's
possibly set up a huge part of just
everything in life is acknowledging
somebody's feelings like just saying I
see that you're really upset I can
understand that
that helps in relationships you also say
people that commit suicide usually don't
do warnings and so they should do it
they just like the ones that serious
that's why if they're doing it you at
least have some hope if your negotiator
yeah alright if they're serious they do
it they wouldn't look for all this
attention and news team cameras and
he'll [ __ ] reason they're gonna do it
they're gonna do it some scary [ __ ] I
don't know I think it's fascinating the
negotiators fasciae so I also think it's
fascinating the people that can go
around talking to serial killers oh
that's that's the most essential but you
know what they say about them gets of
the main thing with serial killers no
matter how [ __ ] up there if they want
to know why they're like this
I'm sure they know all I either yep I
told you about the the guy who Richard
Walter who was doing a profile he's the
guy who created the double helix and he
was giving us the seminar he said and
the serial killer came up and they were
like get him out of here he's a suspect
is there any current serial killers yeah
right now Guga that yes first of all the
saman bomber all the bombing in Austin I
think he's definitely one nine current
serial killers at large here twenty
seven on island killer that's right that
guy with no killer
Jeff there's eight killers Daytona Beach
I'm at the floor this week that can't be
real right being that's pretty real Jim
hey so alright Daytona Chet I'll be over
there if I go missing anyone butcher was
that a headless body if a sex worker was
found yeah South Africa South Africa
okay not worried about that the Maryvale
shooter
where's that Donna okay oh yeah that's
right close the West Meza Bone Collector
a woman walk with her dog discovered
what needed to be a human femur brazil's
rainbow maniac it's by killing gay pz
the driver killer right that's far
highway serial killings yep you know
what this keep me up at night oh man
there's some bad people that's why you
never take a nap in your car are you
serious
I don't know on the side of the road
[ __ ] off I'm not ready for that
wake up and somebody stabbing you the
serial killer things like so hard to
deal with because it's just it's true
evil and mainly serial killers get
excited they get off on the killing most
people kill like mafia guys or whatever
they kill because or there's you gotta
say yeah yeah we're passion then there
are the people that get off on killing
those are that those are the those are
the guys who that the act of killing
that's why they could torture that's why
they'd you know drink your blood
well this is the real-life Texas
Chainsaw Massacre that's real that was
based on a real story
really yeah what I'll tell you about one
of the best horror movies all-time yeah
Jessica Biel's got about kind of rugged
handsome guy with a strong job you could
get me in this van oh yeah get some
low-acid toffee well the scary thing is
they make it they make it at Lenny's
that's okay they make it they make it
their job they get they how they set the
traps it becomes a full-time job for
people you know it's like we get all
honey
they usually have odd jobs or they have
like a like a handyman or they'll do
like a [ __ ] or they have a job like
they're engineers or something it's
really weird but you know like I said
sometimes you'll hear like AG I'll have
um there was one guy who had an antique
shop yep another guy had a trinket
selling treating kids yeah whatever it
is hardware store was low yield like
they think that the Zodiac killer worked
at a hardware store when they still
never got in right great movie
never never till I read that [ __ ]
script that was amazing
great movie they never cut this never
caught him but they think they know who
it was it was based on one guy's
obsession with finding him and died of a
heart attack but found him and found him
in a [ __ ] hardware store I think in
California I praise you Debbie to be one
of those like if
serial killers and then you don't get
caught it'd be hard if you like became
friends something like having a couple
beers right Wow hey baby you're here the
Zodiac killer yeah it was crazy right
like crazy right yeah crazy you're
looking at them yep what yep you're
looking at here's what's really [ __ ]
how hard would that be not to like you
here's what's really [ __ ] up is that
they they tend to be fine with like you
and I because we don't it doesn't turn
them on to kill us they're they're more
into killing something you know they
have a profile they want to kill these
guys that's it then they you're [ __ ]
going
you're they're gonna be a bunch of
Cadbury eggs in a van and if bought in a
just a pot of coffee that's wrong not
low acidic he's like it is we don't want
to bother anyone's stomach good that's
it those are Cadbury eggs yeah and you
peel them for me already cuz I [ __ ]
hate peeling correct correct is that a
box of good and plenties alright man
yeah boom there being and then he's
eating you the way you eat an elk and
you're delicious got some creepy [ __ ] up
there that's what you do sometimes
they'll eat you there are plenty of
serial killers who are also cannibals
and apparently this psychological
profile is that they want to they want
power over you is not enough they want
so much power that they consume you yeah
that's what uh Ted Bundy felt right yeah
I mean Brian's in dark lately chin
fascinating because we're getting sick
we're dying is it that yeah my skin's
explained told you my fin this made me
feel kind of like [ __ ] my father was out
here because I was moving last week and
he's out here helping and he's just the
biggest handyman ever and fraud ever
reason you know he's with my brother a
ton cuz they my brother still lives in
Denver I see my dad once every lately
every three months cuz I have my son now
so you went to see his grandson Tiger
and all that well we don't I mean we'll
talk I check in stuff like that and he
saw me do comedy for the first time at
the common works in Denver all that but
we don't talk a ton you know we used to
be super close we're still it still
loves me but we're in the car together
and he's been with Joanna and my stepmom
and he talks to them non-stop and that
it's never been just meeting him alone
then we're driving the car together it's
just silence I'm like a pipe on the
radar
the radio and then we're driving like
and I could tell my that's trying to
search for something he goes that Conor
McGregor man that Conor McGregor and I'm
all out God he's reaching for that fight
talk Jesus and nothing drives me more
crazy it's my job chocolates I don't
like to talk about it would if I can see
I can tell you what's - you know just to
get dialogue with his son yes that Conor
McGregor here what about him
he goes yeah well he's gonna fight soon
how I'm like no and he's just trying I'm
like no he's not dead here every are you
doing you know trying to get something
going I was gonna taking the gym or
something and then it's dead silence
again it's kind of awkward and I'm it's
hard to make me awkward man and then
just goes hey you're terrible person
this made me feel like [ __ ] tears hey I
just want you to know me now [ __ ] you
are you know it's tough and all that
stuff your grandma's dying
your grandma's dying and I went how old
is she this shows y'all [ __ ] that baby
how old is she goes 97 on it holy [ __ ]
what a run what a run rate Reggie Kray
right goes it has been a good run you
know she's uh you know she's overweight
and stuff to get her going and I don't
know how much longer she has and my
dad's out of whatever 13 kids is the one
who takes care of her and Webster out
and he goes you know who knows how long
she's gonna happen not long and I want
you to know when I call you in let you
know she's passed don't feel don't feel
obligated to go to the funeral we know
it's tough for you to get out here and
uh it's not that big of a deal for you
and he was trying I think to like give
you like Walter give me that pass but
the same time it made me feel like [ __ ]
yeah I was very close to my grandmother
I was doing a play in Sacramento and I
didn't go to the already dead well when
my grandma when my grand I'd my grandma
died who was my mom's mom I was soup
what I was super close with her anytime
I was getting sick my mom would drop me
off at her house she was born raised in
England she's your mother yeah she did
all that you know as far as English
culture and the tea I drink every night
and the cussing she was like The
Osbournes I got cussing and just they're
a hardcore mentality man [ __ ] talking
like they're those bless your
that's where I get the gift I can hit
paste I got all that from my grandma my
uncle and they would always drop this
drop me my brother off over there so
when she passed away and before she did
I would go to the hospital I'd see or a
ton and then I was in training camp
against I think
Mitrione I was in training camp and I
was like three weeks away from the fight
and I was in LA I live in LA at the time
she passed away my aunt nobody called me
and told me my mom told me my brother
called me and told me and I was like
[ __ ] man I'm in the middle of the
biggest fight of my life I'm like what
would grant me to do and I didn't go I
was like there's no I know her she's
like but get the [ __ ] out here and what
I'm ready gun exactly and I called my
mom and told her that I called my
brother like yeah they understand that
makes sense yeah it's a big fight rest
family did not understand a lot of them
don't talk to me anymore really
now all I'm still hold resentment
against me for these to understand yeah
but it's more for them than grant like
pain respects you don't know how I cried
for three days pay respect to talking
about how you know I know everyone deals
with it differently with the funerals I
wouldn't take a person my name I forget
if you need me to pay for it that's your
guys thing gran doesn't need the money
she's gone so if you need help with the
payment I got you whatever but exact are
as my respect to her god my entire life
has been respect if you think by shut up
for one day when you get barriers the
way that she thinks is your way of
showing respect you're wrong I when my
grandmother died I had I felt like I had
gotten so much out of that relationship
both my grandmother and my grandfather
like I got a lot out of that
relationship and I and I did my job as a
grandson like there was a lot of
affection and love and a lot of joy so
one day when they died and when they
died I think is rather sad yeah I felt
guilty about being sad because they had
such a great run such a great life and
they died on their own terms
my dad's mom's very religious and she's
maybe it might be my Qantas with super
religious people she's super religious
super Catholic and obviously 13 kids
[ __ ] you know birth control and all that
it's God's right so it's 13 kids so with
that you know
she was super religious so she was very
judgmental so against with us fighting
that's not God's Way this that's not
God's Way my brother and I would have
beards oh you look like Jesus it's a
hair right Jesus Christ
yeah so there's a good way or in a bad
way Minna back you're a muscular Jesus
if muscular well we don't know he was
pretty shredded in 10 he was he had my
body if I don't work out tan yeah cuz
we're skinny I get Christian chicks love
me for sure but my favor is going this
for you about but Roger she was really
really just oh and then my uncle packs
because he was older and she was super
judgmental towards him well uncle pax is
my ride-or-die
she don't like packs well if you don't
like packs I don't like you yeah that's
how that went down
packs was a real character and you show
you show me that email he sent you yeah
after he saw you perform for the first
time it was a Cubs right yeah smart man
- yeah very much so
Wow yeah but funerals are with those the
funerals are weird did you didn't get a
paksas funeral right I did you did I did
yeah well he what this is the way pax
did it they didn't have your traditional
funeral they had he was part of the
Polar Bear Club in in a Fisherman's
Wharf and it was a very elite club and
they'd swim you know around Alcatraz do
all this stuff and he actually raced a
tugboat he was on he was swimming or he
was on foot and swimming and beat a
tugboat from I forget Catalina Alaska
she's crazy
he loved that's why I love to run I got
right heel up long distance he had his
own marathon all that [ __ ] but in
there's documentaries on it but he he
didn't have yeah [ __ ] sakes did he ever
he didn't have a funeral he had like a
celebration and he had he had all these
awards from running and from college
football and boxing the Olympics and
other stuff and it was it took up
consumed the house so my aunt and they
decided that he was going to have a
celebration there's food there's a stage
and all this close friends and family
and then all his awards and all his
paintings and sculptures were round and
you could grow up and take it
damn you could friends could take him I
took his uh this golden trophy that then
it's the center of my house
and it's uh it's a gold trophy 21 mr.
universe says packs back to bill mr. mr.
band's name was packs fact that's his
real name
packs yeah and that's my son's middle
name packs but that's the way to do it I
hope you would get up and talk like you
looked of that yes [ __ ] hell yes yeah
that was the way to do it I agree 100% I
woke my grandmother was not very
she wasn't wasn't very sentimental she
was you know this thing for the
afterlife if there is one and then once
you I had to walk her my grandfather had
an open casket
by the way hey [ __ ] open casket I didn't
recognize my grandfather I was like
who's the wax statue in there first of
all I didn't look the whole thing was a
disaster but doesn't matter so I walk
her and she was gonna say goodbyes they
closed the casket and stuff like that my
grandma was just so amazing she goes I
go
you wanna go she goes oh boy walks over
thing that was it cried a little bit
cried like like she had a cold
imagine me the person get those bodies
ready that's a weird gig I have well and
also there is if there is a bus ample
evidence that deliver catch you people
would get into that and volunteer to
work there sometimes can yeah
don't let though let me catch you trying
to rehabilitate my grandma [ __ ] it's
probably more common than we think right
now oh you think I do I actually do
disgusting I think that we as human
beings put ourselves in doors well let
me ask you something why would you want
to why do you want to be around dead
bodies all the time honestly it's a very
important function I'm not saying the so
let's do it some more Tories are passed
down the family but run businesses but
I'm just I'm just asking you sir I'm
asking you I mean I'm talking about the
guy who's is that line of work
yeah but they say that around kids all
the time why do you want to be the Santa
Claus well kids are all but different
here's why kids I can make a difference
I can actually make a difference in
someone's life when it really shall
above all right correct if I'm a if I'm
gonna be the Easter Bunny next Sunday
we'll see now you're asking important
questions you're asking and I've never
trusted those kid you know your your
your man in your 30s near a camp
counselor for boys your what's really
can we talk about that for a sec because
I don't want to be personally being
I don't know let's call it a 9 10 year
old I got I got a shelf life with five
men get me the [ __ ] 10 of them I'm
excited some tight knots yeah no I'm not
going to the middle of the [ __ ] yes I
love the Boy Scouts I love that I think
it's awesome
I think the we blows the cuffs so I
don't trust those counselors well tell
you that right now
it bothers me that's your agenda it's
it's and I'm not saying oh it's why it's
let's just give everybody the benefit
out but it's definitely why you don't
have one guy alone with all those boys
or one guy alone with one boy you just
did you're on the side of course out
older dudes who've been doing it way too
are on the side of caution yeah it's for
sure all gotta colleges are gonna have a
nurse in the room and they're examining
ja do you know mall mall bunnies don't
the mall bunny
it's weird [ __ ] man yeah clowns in their
50s clowns don't really exist anymore
though do they saw one absolutely saw
one in at the mall the outdoor mall he
was blowing balloons on Third Street
that's right sir and it's v yeah those
guys are there but they're just crazy
and they can't come up with a new
[ __ ] bit yeah they're getting behind
paint they might be living alone yeah
something's I'll tell you what I enjoy a
good robot man I enjoy those when they
paint their entire skin which that must
take forever all silver long time
transformation back see Miss Martin
yeah he stands there until you do
something's off yeah I respect that
husband that's not easy
that's hustle that's awesome should be
some current events final talk about
more death and [ __ ] dead bodies yeah
let's do some card sheets that you we
usually piss for experiments let's go
pee okay God if you guys want to stab
your eyes out we have to take a break
because Brian taught those doctor I've
lost I wanna say 20% respect for you
talk about the biggest [ __ ] I've ever
heard all I did was talk to her I was
freaking out if I don't you said I have
no I thought that was a joke I when I
was not no no
they all were dead soon
WebMD and don't go on WebMD cuz they'll
tell you have cancer or Concha I'm like
what the [ __ ] is wrong with me
when your body a little bit not real
ittle bit I'm not locked me in a bump on
your nose I was a high
I would I would have taken all the
medicine no your jury we're able to go
see the doctor I'm even by the way how
about this this is how much of a
hypochondriac I'm ready I'm not I
haven't been to the dermatologist
because we have to shoot something about
do a podcast I wanna shut everything
down but I'm not gonna do that
in fact I'm not going to the doctor but
I saw like I got a call you're a little
bit during that you're a little worried
about it well no they're only amazed I
was it was getting worse and worse
because I think yeah well you felt by
change your diet because everything I
read says it kind of works they go yeah
you know six weeks eight weeks okay I
mean how about I change my diet Sundin
well for the long term the diet yeah
take the pills now she'd see get by the
way she said don't do it because it
causes this Magnezone red flag with your
doctor anyway or the red flag yeah don't
take those pills take vitamin C you know
sick should take less vitamin C no you
missed it no she said I swear on my life
shape take vitamins she never mentioned
vitamin C she look at me she said tackle
annex
know tackle in exchange she's not take
lots vitamin C she's like take extra
vitamins take a surviving scene here
that's a huge right here vitamin c CZ me
and chin both aren't wrong here brother
no no but she but she's been practicing
forever she said she said tackle an axe
that's really what I got to do you know
she said that but then she said you're
feeling or take vitamin C that's proven
I was sick that's proven to be a hoe
yeah she's a very good dermatologist who
was it that Aubrey O'Day ah let's go
back to this
hey let's let's get off my psoriasis its
you be God
I can't don't ever call doctor on me
again oh I don't know why that chin I
was asking questions
oh my god what do you got this is I'm
just looking at this all right - let's
see who that is she was all Edie's
girlfriend she looks hot yes yeah they
went to they did a reality show together
- yeah there's a bit of a train wreck
that I think there are like couples
something real yeah I mean like when you
see a girl
you almost like automatic default you're
like well that's it's a little bit like
a my it burns when I pee
well that's not normal I see that single
yeah you go you go beautiful but like
I'm looking at all the pictures not just
that one I'm like there's that's not
somebody I'm gonna get into a heavy
relationship with and move her in I mean
chances are chances are you're gonna run
into some issues but why are you
bringing this up to now I was just
looking at it but I think she was with
Diddy - she was with PT - well a while
back we can say with that means she's
just hiding it Nick she did he never
claimed it go ahead let me see some more
pictures but there why are there picture
of her just there no this so this is
Barstow they're talking about her having
an affair with Donald Trump jr. while he
was with his wife so it's just an
remember talk yeah but uh if you want to
see more pictures over yeah well yeah
just know for researched I want to see
she's had no well she was way way
prettier before she is senior - right
yeah she was in a group oh she was in
now that's her with Pauly D so that's
how she used to look really pretty yeah
really pretty what band was she and she
was on the she's on P Diddy's band yeah
that's that's a good I should be does
she look so different now though right
how old is she um she had a ton of work
done I lost you what branches with real
quick what's the other band they created
they broke up yeah so a fifth harmony
fit so he woke up she was in fifth
harmony no no no fifth army broke up
though yeah vacant the band Danity Kane
making the band 3d making it the band
with P Diddy know he liked you guys
while making the business you do
whatever it takes
I like cheesecake there in Manhattan and
you'd have to walk to like the Bronx and
it was like I forget it was like
midnight
like I want cheesecake y'all need to
give me my cheesecake
you have four hours to get it done and
he's looking at the map and Ike and it's
gonna take you about four hours if it's
not four hours all you were fired
they're like why freak out let go do it
it's dangerous - they beat heels
- she ever see when you're in Cosmo cuz
you have dudes running dialyzer slashing
frats do you ever have that where they
were they do no no
you didn't have that in your culture
there's frats at CU but but didn't
hazing oh my god you see these guys are
I don't know do I look like they came to
me and say they're like hey man that's
okay start middle ain't doing that [ __ ]
or my own what do I have to do run
around with a towel on my head for three
weeks kids die there in those hazing
it's just oh here it is dylon dial on
dial on oh my god that show was great
and they did rap there's beau my god no
one ever made it from the show but it's
[ __ ] classic his bass EP did he just
shown how much better he is than these
kids and make him do horrible [ __ ] and
then tried to put him on tour and all of
them had serious problems well get to
keep people off yes classic yeah what do
you got - all right well speaking of
those bands fifth harmony broke up today
No
[Music]
let's cry together ready or sue solo
careers yeah oh thank god the odds
aren't well you know what they're doing
is I think your name's Camilla you know
that come here come on good today
Kamiya Cabella yes she has that song
could be more vana have any Havana I
brought up in Havana
so anyways she's [ __ ] killing it so
they're probably like look at her oh
we're all gonna go individual never
works she that Camilla is the one as
always one it was the one she's the
Beyonce group yeah just until I give
your broom on not all you're gonna make
it matter of fact none of you thought I
was doing that TV they cook pulled a
couple of us aside they go look we know
you guys are going to be the breakout
characters these other guys are not I
was like are you talking to me like this
first of all they're all more talented
than I am and I never was the breakout
character let's keep going well she's
[ __ ] adore how the other girls are
trying to do it to she's young I wonder
if she didn't 150 r1 year-olds who look
like a pineapple maybe hey baby I got
good news and what else yes gin good
news is I'm 51 I got a lot of wisdom bad
news is that a big-ass fallen they're
winning a shitload of awards and then
just they just break up I had a problem
with her so she so she bounced she
bounced and then now they're all and
then there was only four of them yet
they still refer to themselves as say
[ __ ] I mean you when they should refer
themselves this fourth harmony she's she
probably started to realize that people
get she's like you guys suck people get
in your air agents people get in your
ear right but it's very but it's very
evident if there's one more talented one
like Beyonce she's like god I could keep
doing this touring with you three or I
could just make all the money myself and
[ __ ] you guys you know it'd be like it'd
be like if we had this amazing podcast
also you know you just go off and sign
with CAA and they give you your own bang
you get your own podcast that's all good
and then yeah Showtime it's good Oh
congratulations name I got a flight in
your flight so time no II
you got three things going on I hope
let's play about me
and you tell you rolling I'm beyond
thing that's exactly what's [ __ ] you
know what Kelly Rowland's I'm not a
[ __ ] myth I'm not though kept this
Kelly Rowland is Kelly Rowland covered
in psoriasis
she's covered in goop that psoriasis or
whatever you call it
[ __ ] man this is not good but also
remembered like that the fifth harmony
it was like a competition they like they
were form like oh here you guys are
friends tour
like we don't [ __ ] like each other
but do it for business cheating you out
the dynamics like that's why we look you
like Aerosmith Rolling Stones Bruce
Springsteen like these bands that travel
together
blink-182 obviously their guide dips out
but these bands who do it for so many
years in metallic and there's all these
different dynamics how they do it man is
unbelievable I think especially for
girls I think with girls just be cat and
times harder
cuz girls like I don't I don't get along
with girls I've more died friends dick
dick dick is so true girls I just don't
relate to them they're so catty they're
haters two-vehicle dick dick dick dick
100% I get along with guys better oh
cool anal I agree that's the way my mind
works when I hear that I think you're
right I think you're right and those
girls are my favorite so there I said
yeah I'm like I hear you I don't have
any girl we do the same dick dick dick
hey you [ __ ] all your all your friends
all the guys you hang out you [ __ ]
them at least once you're gonna deny it
but we all know that you had all the
truth that's okay
chin when you're in a band was there
some dynamics where you guys just
there's trouble you know it's weird the
one guy that was trouble for us like he
didn't practice as much as we wanted was
the guy that made it huge oh that's
because already he's the talented one
yeah seriously because he was the
talented one but I hate it yet I was
like what nah man but we were we always
got along but odd the only thing I was
pissed off about was like if they didn't
come in and well there's two people in
the group so they're really super
talented one junior and then another guy
Jimmy who just didn't practice as much
you know Jimmy didn't practice as much
so I knew he didn't practice and we all
sounded kind of bad because of one
person so me I got pissed off at that
stuff sure I've always looked at it as
pair like as what it's fair like the
person that hustle
and works the smartest and like I knew
you were gonna be successful I knew
right away as soon as we started doing
the podcast I was watching the way
you're around the business and thinking
about [ __ ] I don't think about and I was
like and I might mean I said that to you
I said you know you play your cards
right and you could be a [ __ ] real
star be a long ways do I know that
talking like that I know but your
success in the business and I say this
to people all the time
it's actually an important thing but a
lot of people works - no I'm sorry right
people work hard you can't just say I'm
success because I work as a difference
there's a difference so it's working
hard could be like moving a rock from
here to there over and over it's not
that you're working hard you you show up
every day and you grind it there's no
question about that you're comfortable
in that routine but you're also sitting
down and thinking and studying the
landscape and saying what needs to
change what how do I need to adjust my
approach and that's just a fact I see
you do it all the time
yeah you're watching you're watching
Kevin Hart you're watching other people
you're talking to people who've been
here for a long time talk to me you're
always taking information and you're
adjusting your approach so you know yeah
yeah that that's never been surprised to
me I told you a long time ago I said you
know watching you do with this I was
like that's kind of habit that's a
culture that you've assimilated that's a
that's a mindset and success is a
[ __ ] mindset man it just is
transformational loved in your regular
yes man and working smart you know I'm I
don't know no long way to go though
you're talking like a Camila Cabello or
whatever the [ __ ] you David I'll tell
you what you've done to me is now that I
have these my I wear my cool shoes those
two boots and I saw dude I saw dude I
was doing stand-up last night and he had
shoes on I can't believe I'm this guy
and he had he had these big [ __ ] shoes
on and he had white laces that were
hanging and dragging on the ground and
he was probably every bit of 33 goo till
I went and I went he's all right and I
went and I just look and I go you sir
need to change your shoes I can't have
you wear in those black shoes with a
problem these are laughing I thought I
thought yeah I go but girls are not
gonna like you and it's just they're not
gonna jump trying to do you solid yeah
sure the first thing women judge by the
way
yes exactly hey what else you got good
one
all right this is the ski lift I was
talking about
this is in Georgia but the Russian
Russia Georgia yeah so since it's in
Russia yeah it's where Stalin came from
so what happens now I check this ski
lifts malfunction out and it's so
terrifying I've never seen somebody that
sells this terrifying so you know how
they lift down lock oh it's moving it's
moving why is it reading so fast it's on
turbo mode engine malfunction
malfunction damn are those people okay
down there we'll keep checking out keep
looking at oh it keeps hitting town get
down so everyone's telling me jump off
jump off because it's getting crazier
and crazier on that other side of it oh
whoa you definitely get off at the you
want jump at when it goes gonna jump
they are there but they have no idea
they just they just see something crazy
happening and it gets even worse look at
this I saw one gangster jump hello
john-boy jump jump in hell early but
don't jump that early jump kids little
bear oh [ __ ] bro holy [ __ ] do we know
what happened to these people don't see
that again oh that's awful
[ __ ] get the kids off get the little
kids off God you gotta get the kids off
some what there are no one heard know of
no deaths double brain trauma thank God
whew whew concuss who that could be such
a horrible thing to watch [ __ ]
do so though they're investigating the
manufacturer right now you gotta get
down let's take that bridge that
collapsed in Florida they built in six
hours
they're like speed guy they like built
it that fast and they should six hours
and even they're like God I don't know
man
Jesus cuz then they open up the people
then it's six people died around [ __ ]
yeah ridiculous let's put a little more
time Dabra seen those root bridges where
they build like it's the wettest place
on earth root and they build a
they build bridges out of the roots of
trees and they can carry like 35 people
at a time it's [ __ ] wild there you go
I love don't you love Google what did we
do it I go like in the photos that
that's they they just start the with
bamboo scaffolding they start growing
the roots mmm and in like 20 years you
got a bridge look forward to that that
takes a long time yeah you better 24 to
20 30 years okay 20 years 30 years we're
passing this bad boy
it's or we just walk across the shallow
and play something on the earth on the
earth
what's place on earth little sketch in
all right
people have been sending me this one a
father of a kid with Down syndrome so
this kid with Down syndrome he's a boy
scout and his dream is to become an
Eagle Scout love it
and then this the organization allowed
him to get up the ranks and then he did
a project to where he would earn enough
merit badges to become an Eagle Scout
and then finally when he got to that
point they rejected it they say you
can't be an Eagle Scout why because he's
not going through the proper protocols
to become a real hey [ __ ] off Cub Scouts
you guys need to know the pressure you
handle in your dying [ __ ]
organization do the kid a favor man
those goddamn bad probably a little bit
more complicated than there probably is
it's the boy if I'm really nice to him
and they private and supportive of us
but okay so you let him have an Eagle
Scout is it the end of the world
oh [ __ ] off you know what in Boy Scouts
yes or the Boy Scouts Girl Scouts you
guys are the shittiest vision hey guys
do we make cookies for tagging sakes
your way out cookie I haven't I don't
like delicious Girl Scout I don't like
your attitude
listen now I got them [ __ ] do not let
them put this to me tonight we shape the
badges I can't let you get that's [ __ ]
up man
listen me listen you can't let sceptile
he buys a whole division being an eagle
look at he's got a lot of badges and
he's he's earned it he's earned it he
said I also don't honey dick the kid
it's been his life going it's the topic
you know what yeah now this is a high
solder we can have well there's a limit
you know what you're a bad person [ __ ]
you bad person look listen hey real
quick you sided with the Boy Scouts the
girlscouts says a lot about a man Boy
Scout Girl Scout I'm not in a court of
law nonfat Sakura no let's just say it's
big aside boy
what makes delicious cookies they
invented the Thin Mint the other does
nothing but Rob my man here why not
they built fires timeouts and they're
good citizens that clean parks
you mean organize camping and [ __ ] make
yeah and we all get to wear a suit
I'm Girl Scout yeah there you go Girl
Scouts do have some thin mints serve you
my daughter my daughter it's my
daughter's Girl Scout what 10mins
right there are they in a silver package
that's how they come no not mine hey get
down no we get the status dater brothers
in front of a state of I can't eat it my
psoriasis are they in a green package
yeah so they had Girl Scout logos on
them yeah understand with silver package
just try it
mama even heals delivery now so I'll eat
done that Meal box I mean it my daughter
my daughter goes this [ __ ] though did
you freeze them I did everyone's only
freezin it do you like I do taste little
[ __ ] Simoes to know Tagalog it's more
now I got some ores man you know your
girls they ran out or something you like
your sweets bro ah [ __ ] yeah I'm a
goddamn American Girl Scout cookie my
girlfriend growing down Girl Scout
cookies I yep let me tell you what would
you doing this is my girls my daughter's
a Girl Scout
so they said anybody with a cough you
just don't come because they're all the
seven kids to attempt youth fit so sure
enough the two Scout does two Scout
leaders they're women their daughters
couldn't come they were crying but they
were sick they're like can't do it kid
shows up mom goes gives her here's your
cough medicine don't forget did he go
did she have cars no she's fine she's
getting over it my daughter's missed two
days of school cuz she came home the
next day I was like who who brought the
[ __ ] seal is there a seal that's this
shitty bad everything like I take my kid
with that god I was like give me a
pretty much of that play place and
there's a kid who just sniffles McGee
snot bubbles Danny's doing a shitty job
the rich moms doing a shitty job and
I'll just look and if he's if he's
around him or the kid super sick we just
dip out well I can't have him getting
sick I don't wanna get sick only that
mom good you know what [ __ ] you how
about that dude your kids my wife is
obsessed with it he's so he's cute
[ __ ] here's a rough ones oh yeah he's
a Ruffin
yeah his son he likes arrest his son is
boy he's all boy like you throw a ball
at him I'm not joking you throw a Nerf
ball at his face and it's not a soft one
something okay
listen all children that I've seen turn
their face where they squint the kids
eyes our [ __ ] is wide open
they are lanterns lanterns right in the
face boom catches it or doesn't comes
back for more comes back for more
hurling his entire body against the
couch falling off the couch hitting you
where Johnny night throwing combos yeah
we watched the n-c-double-a wrestling
finals and then he just was attacking he
decided to attack yeah he's got delts
he's got tells all boy and a chest it's
trouble what else yeah chin give this
kid his goddamn ego bad huh for sure I
had to it um do you remember this kid
the affluenza teen he there's a problem
he did it
what Oh the Apple was a team yeah so he
was he was in a drunk driving accident
where he killed four people and his
defense because he comes from a super
rich you know crazy rich family his his
law defense said it's affluence he has
no idea what's what's right what's wrong
yeah so anyways turns out he got like a
weight lighter sentence than he should
have
well he should have had like 20 years in
prison stays in Texas I believe was
right Wow Texas real yeah a lot of money
I know but I'm saying to the others
you're pretty Stern in Texas now look
man his life is done so he's gonna be
out in two weeks God's punishment that
he was 16 years old we should all take
into account he was 16 years old he got
drunk and got behind the wheel could it
happen to anybody
he's 16 there has to be repercussions
though you killed four innocent people
did four years in jail for did 4016 so
he's 20 now what I'm saying what I'm
saying is that the the fact of the
matter is for people is unacceptable but
oh you served two
you can put him in jail forever or you
can you know I don't know I don't so I
do I think I think he has to deal with
the guilt and all the stuff that comes
with having killed four people he's
gonna be in court for a long time
probably with uh you know lawsuit
healthy home away forever I don't think
in two years now the thing is when
you're 16
what what you have to say is that
catastrophe happened but at the same
time he was a 16 year old who was drunk
who got into a car and drove how many
people have done that right I didn't do
that
I didn't either but I'm saying a lot of
people have and it doesn't mean that
they deserve to be killed essentially I
shouldn't be killed but this should be a
slap on the wrist yeah well there there
might be a way to use his example and
what he did to make things better I
don't know is is there is that that is
that a viable question yeah maybe can't
be killing people in getting to you know
but so he did violate his promotion when
when it first happened he violated his
probation cuz he wasn't supposed to have
any alcohol then a video appeared where
he was drinking alcohol yeah and then he
left the country with his mom what she
was not supposed to do so he did a few
things wrong yeah I saw you just
thinking of a [ __ ] about the law it
seems like he does have some sort of
weird mental
maybe disability going on there but
either way I don't think you'd want to
be him in any circumstance and and it's
a you know field all the money in the
world yeah we also know that your brain
at sixteen is not fully developed you
know people say that but that's not a
cop-out for your actions well it's it's
why you don't it is been in the sense
that this is why you don't try minors as
adults and the reason you don't data is
very very specific because the child's
brain has not been fully it's not fully
developed but they know right from wrong
more imposed Oh from that doesn't give
you a free ride nobody said it does he
went to jail it makes you were massive I
think it was 16 went to jail for two
he's 20 now I think was just 2 years
that's 2 years who said two years in
jail so and then probation yeah I don't
know I don't know we can debate how long
I don't hold I pulled up by my bright on
he served he said each sentence of two
years in jail after the judge Wayne
ordered he served four to say it's also
you don't serve two of the
for yeah you know again it's a question
of proportion
we could have debated how long he should
do I just think that when you kill
somebody and you're that kid you've
already you have a life sentence to an
extent for people yeah for people
destroyed for live for families [ __ ]
this lip Romney's learn nothing though
cuz soon as he was on probation he's
taking part in the drinking game oh sure
he might be an alcoholic or he might
have major problems he might have brain
issues that's my magining he does yeah
affluenza was just a wild 16 year old
that likes a party yeah and got drunk
killed a bunch of people and I still
partying maybe didn't learn anything I
don't know uh-huh
maybe he's a [ __ ] the reason why this
did make head on to the beginning
because they actually use that as it got
away with it
affluenza yeah wow I heard that I heard
affluenza mmm raised by nannies you know
parents aren't there you know I mean
he's not he doesn't it's a tough way to
look I don't know the whole thing's a
disaster disaster all the way around
what else yet Jim this is obvious
already but Floyd Mayweather applied for
anime license yep he said his wrestling
was at a level seven in a couple months
he'll get it to a level nine hilarious
here's a good one the rock so his dad
had had to have a hip surgery so the
rock replaced his hips or got in the hip
surgery dad was a wrestler right yeah
that was a start and then he told his
dad like his dad was saying he can't
drive the same vehicle right now because
of his hip issue so Rock said just get
whatever you think you need to get and
then his dad posted a picture and sent
this to the rock with a brand new
Cadillac Escalade that's great a Bigelow
you know there's yeah there's so nice
listen you've been one of those
Escalades sure have you can't like does
it right they do do it right you know
I've looked at you know poor shows and
all this and then Unitec oh yeah there's
a reason why they've been killing
hundred percent maybe the best SUV on
the road
Granta you might look like an uber
driver from time to time but she's worth
it's a luxury vehicle a nice it's a nice
kid that's
a smooth luxury vehicle yeah I mean the
rockbind his dad of Escalade it's pretty
cool but that's like that's like me buy
my dad a Snickers bar his bank account
yeah like by dad whatever he wants
that's good
I mean right yeah I think you and I are
pretty generous that way for sure
I'll buy a lot of peopIe I'll buy some
people some [ __ ] what else get you um I
don't know how much this means to but a
northern why I know the last one the
last one died the last one is there's 45
though right yeah but do this he's not
white though is he I thought they were
white what are they gonna do with that
[ __ ] horn they're trying to breed him
I guess you can bring them back on the
market with that horn while we jacked
that thing off steal the sperm and make
a bunch more than the last hour doing
that yeah so there's two left that his
family members don't one granddaughter
why they call them white I don't know
things look so young right
you ever see a rhino like this whoa look
at the size of that [ __ ]
hey dude oh the size of a man Oh have
you ever seen a little rhino bro that
thing's head is it the size of a man
it's a rhino but its head is the size of
a man all right man sorry you know if
you ever see a rhino when a ride on the
side you know a water buffalo they
consider the most dangerous hanumon
Africa oh yeah the club black lime tree
and they're huge me see what this is you
ever see a rhino tussle with a water
buffalo and what it does to a water
buffalo hmm right oh [ __ ] a water
buffalo up six ways to Sunday bro that
black one looks more like a white runner
than the white one
well there's 5,000 it says greatly in
danger that's a lot of rain oh no it's
not buddy it's just not damn look
there's only so much me seven job in
rhinos
yeah very few Wow the white rhino
there's 21,000 come on only a hundred
and sixty-seven come on a hundred of
those brown ones we need more that you
know our job is and you are Sumatra is
I'm ten points now a Sumatra is that
Indonesia it is Tunisia
Java and there's rhinos in Indonesia
there are
yes they're Islands is also Chicago
there certainly are sir
very integers they're also given monkeys
there's the reticulated python there's
also cope and what is the what is the
what is the one ape found in the
indonesian archipelago and iran your
tangos thank you sir for Angleton thank
you please say uncle right now I want to
have I want to back up for a second you
were raised by a British grandma correct
can you do a British accent no I can't
don't have much of an ear they tried you
know the peel I've tried to give me
doing when I was at the Aussie they're
like a free English France can do
English accent I just can't
now I don't know how to do it can I grew
up around it yeah you can't hear it and
mimic it no Kenny was right
I've tried it doesn't work it's just now
you guys with accents cuz you're means I
should I do
yeah some yeah British like that say
sort of like this sort of like this sort
of like this sort of like sort of like
right in the back of your back of you
all right you can say they're men sort
of line there so yeah do you not I mean
you don't mean do you not I mean you're
not I mean do you not like it you know I
mean do you know I mean you know I mean
yeah yeah now yeah yeah yeah right right
so right right right right no no I don't
know I don't come on do it taste a at
that now say about well that doesn't
sell me say 11 11 11 11
no you're not good at score sir far
closer yes sir yeah get your pizza get
your pizza yeah it's our lovely get your
pizza that's it
well shut up to the Rhinos hopefully get
more chance to the Rhinos let's work on
that Jack them off and I'll work out my
accent um and and and speaking of we're
both at a town man tomorrow
well my shows not till Thursday Thursday
Tampa improv I'm there Thursday night
one show is left and then Friday
Saturday west palm Palm Beach improv
Sunday
Orlando hey circular in Daytona don't
come out
because I will be equipped with zebras I
don't know what if I tell you next week
I'm in San Jose San Jose Improv Thursday
Friday Saturday Thursday Friday Saturday
San Jose now say that go this week poor
talker get your tickets also April
Bakersfield and Calgary Yuk Yuk's those
tickets just went on sale Calgary end of
April but beginning of April Bakersfield
there are 30 tickets left for my show in
Bakersfield Yuk Yuk's those are going
fast already they told me get them T
back a calm bride the kickdown tell
we're gonna beat a little flame throwing
a flamethrower this is my impression
ation of Brian yeah yeah bring your
retardant material abroad our well
retardant means it not does is our word
grunts that's actually props rear to a
fire retardant burp out repellent and
because our clothing because I'm gonna
be at the West Palm Beach improv oh we
both there yeah April 19 20 21 I'm at
laughs Boston and Boston Massachusetts
throwing flames
Rona Denver the next weekend April 2000
I let you in my city I let you in my
city you're welcome you're welcome for
Comedy Works downtown get your [ __ ]
tickets now you sons-of-bitches years I
let you with my suit II let you in my
suit here
yeah yeah there it is think yes
listening this is the finally kid we out